in various cities from new delhi
to lahore
to dhaka
[Applause]
to jakarta
muslim worshipers gathered after friday
prayers to voice their opposition to
comments made by an indian politician
we are protesting as an indian woman
made bad comments about the character of
our beloved prophet muhammad so we are
here
napo sharma is the target of their anger
the former spokeswoman for india's
governing bjp made comments about the
prophet muhammed during a tv debate that
many say were derogatory protesters want
her arrested for hate speech
only one police complaint has been
lodged against nepal sharma and despite
that she has not been arrested yet she
should be arrested as soon as possible
and stringent action should be taken
against her
sharma has been suspended while the
party's media head in new delhi naveen
kumar jindal has been expelled he's also
accused of making insulting remarks
the bjp says it strongly denounces
insults against any religion sect or
ideology but the backlash is growing the
prime minister of india should come or
and address the nation
i would say particularly the 200 million
muslims and
try to assure them that they will their
rights and freedoms will be protected in
india as guaranteed by the constitution
countries in the gulf region including
qatar and iran have summoned india's
envoys and demanded a public apology but
these protesters want more they want
napo sharma arrested charged and
prosecuted for comments they say are
offensive to islam
victoria gatenby al jazeera